[Music]
Wednesday Bonnie run supposed to perform
at a big event in Las Vegas but a
medical crisis forced to change of plans
Tuesday night after the voice live show
she suffered a ruptured eardrum and
reportedly received treatment at
cedars-sinai hospital in Los Angeles the
eardrum emergency caused when to
withdraw from singing at the power of
love charity gala last night in Las
Vegas and I witness at the gala tells ET
an announcement was made saying when had
ruptured an eardrum and couldn't sing
under doctor's orders
[Music]
[Applause]
Jennifer Hudson stepped in at the gala
to fill in for Gwen John Bongiovi also
performed and a videotape was played at
the event where Gwyn expressed her
regrets
she told the audience quote I am so
sorry that I cannot attend tonight just
Monday night et spoke to Gwen at the
voice I really love the process like I'm
like perfect for the show so will Wendy
back in her coach's chair at The Voice
this coming Monday night a source tells
us she is expected to be there a
ruptured eardrum can be a serious injury
for a singer and possibly lead to them
being unable to perform for major
lengths of time